AC podcast saw our video and they
decided they wanted to react to it and
at one point in the video Ethan starts
talking about building a bridge you know
forgiveness all this other stuff and
they start asking some of the people
around the staff members what they think
and one person in particular has an
issue the researcher uh Olivia I don't
mean to uh break up the Bridge Building
here but they did go after Olivia I was
think wait what happened about that okay
you don't know who Olivia is she's the
loser feminist researcher they
on we got you're right we'll bring the
TNT out and I just don't like the whole
Narrative of trying to like pile on like
there's a beef between you and Hassan
therefore I'm out yeah oh no you guys I
how can I build a bridge by myself brid
the bridge is made of paper Mach they
could they could maybe make a pece
offering to you
Olivia no not happening is the Damage
Done I I don't really I can move forward
in my life things but I don't really
forgive if they said you know what sorry
we said that we didn't know anything
about you we were wrong o really I feel
like Olivia is usually so quick to
forgive too it really depends depends on
how black they are
yeah has nothing to do with that I have
a hard time forget black people I was
like trying to
relate may come across the sincere and
they'll melt your heart maybe maybe um
what you said it wasn't this what was it
no it was when I was talking about my
experience I think they like zoomed in
on me my face being really upset and
they flashed to Amber
herd they did they played like sad music
over her wait they did that they
did O that's [__]
up I thought this was going to be a
peaceful video but now it's just all the
pain is I'm just digging the pain back
up back up
can you pull that I do you mind if I
watch that to J my
memory why would they do that because
they suck uh because we never did that
that's why and unfortunately they never
played the clip on stream so nobody can
see the context but I will play the clip
for you guys what she claims is us
making fun of her experience now let me
be clear about two things one I never
knew anything ever happened to this lady
and two our comments had nothing to do
with her personal experience but you
don't have to believe my word I'm going
to play this clip and you see what you
want to see mind
you the video that she's talking about
we had referenced how someone was lying
about somebody else it was proven in a
lot of different ways that she was
making up certain details about a story
of sexual misconduct okay these guys are
honestly as bad and in some cases worse
because I see them serving as a Gateway
into this really toxic
manosphere uh phobic misogynistic people
who aren't racist who aren't misogynist
are tired of being called [__] racist
misogynist pieces of [__] by people like
you cuz people are tired of being like
feel like they're racist misogynist
pieces of [__] from the social justice
Warrior movement where you can't
possibly say anything without offending
someone this Cult of outrage people are
sick of
[Music]
it women be trying to ruin men's lives
it's CL it's just what they do I'm going
to go out of my way to lie
so I'm just going to lie about me that
is such an insanely hurtful thing to say
about any woman ever it's a very
humiliating experience to go through
something like that and for for anyone
to assume that like someone claiming
being a victim or surviving something is
them like wanting to boost their is so
incredibly wrong and inin and uninformed
that like you 1 million per should not
be making content about this because
you're teaching young men who don't know
anything about this and then you're
telling young women to not talk to each
other to not talk to anyone to not tell
anyone that something happened because
idiots like you and you know what you
sound like a feminist loser though if
I'm just going to interject I do she's
the loser feminist researcher who spends
all her Day on Reddit boards and thinks
that's research okay sorry guys I'll
take it back mind you that's not me
editing that they edited to the
soundboard and right in the middle of
what she's talking they started playing
that [__] that's [__] up that's
hilarious that's [__] up I was like
yeah you said tell her you know
you is The Zo and the Ember thing yeah
do you understand why we did the Amber
herd thing because because the story of
am herd is exactly what you described
but am herd lied yeah that's it we're
not saying that you are Amber herd we're
just saying that what you're
saying just H it just had
happened go Ahad sorry yeah yeah but if
you want to take it like that you want
to take it like that that's fine but you
have to understand like get out of your
feelings and be like okay let's
understand a big picture they're not
good at that I think for these people a
lot of them probably didn't watch the
clip because again self admittedly a lot
of them don't like to watch stuff they
just hear from others and then take
their word yeah okay if you watch the
clip in its entirety relating it to her
personal experience like bro I don't
watch you guys I don't know what she's
been through I didn't know anything
about her other than one video so how
would I know she's ever been through any
experience like that to me to call her a
liar about her that's ridiculous the
Amber her was obviously about someone
lying since the video we were talking
about was about somebody lying that's it
don't don't make it out about something
else we' done plenty of videos where men
have done inappropriate things with
women and we've called them out for it
we don't think that all women lie about
this stuff we don't think that most
women lie but some of them do and it's
okay to say that we should not be
accepting of people who make false
accusations that's it but you guys
running with this narrative you laughed
at this victim no I laugh at Liars the
same way I would laugh at okay if you
want to DD women I'mma laugh at you if
you want to lie about being diddled
I'mma laugh at you that's it now I can
understand that when you've personally
been through something and maybe people
have doubted you be despite you having
gone through it that someone saying
something like this makes you feel
targeted but you have to understand just
the same way you've been a victim of
someone harming you there's other people
who've been victims of someone lying
about them okay and I'm being empathetic
towards that experience I didn't
discount yours I didn't say something
bad that happened to you didn't happen
I'm saying something bad has happened to
somebody else and it's okay to look at
the person who's the perpetrator of such
thing and mock them that's it I was I
was disagreeing with the statement you
made that the idea that women would lie
about yes some women do unfortunately I
wish you guys were the perfect gender I
wish it was the case that no women lied
but the truth is some of them do it's
okay to admit that and I think that
happen is that those people that lie
when you understand where we're coming
from is that those people that
lie actually affect people like you that
something actually happened and then we
don't believe you because other people
lie y out of all the people out of
everybody you should be more pissed at
the people that are
lying and hold people that are lying
accountable funny it's it's just it's
just crazy that you take no it's just
that it's crazy that you take all that
energy to make sound Clips but not
listen to videos I find that I'm very
very as much [__] as I talk I find that
I'm very happy or very quick to forgive
that being said they wronged Olivia and
that's not something I can forgive right
thank you I absolutely give you guys
100% all of the power to forgive on your
own I personally am just like not going
to
entertain okay them that much that's
fair were we trying to find that time
stamp of what they said about oh liia I
think it might be a bridge building
moment I think it might but I don't know
because I can't read their
minds this so weird this is the feels
like high school or like Middle School
where someone has a crush on you it's
like yo does does Steven across the
street like me what is this from listen
what the hell is hold on I've already
said this okay this is not new I'm not
going to say nothing I haven't already
said I've already said that politically
speaking we have more in common that we
have part when you guys call us
conservatives or grifters all the stuff
I just disagreed y'all can check out
those videos I stand today where I stand
before I don't like some of the tax you
can do when you don't like somebody and
how disingenuous you can be at those
times cuz when you have a hate boner for
somebody sometimes you're like this I
don't like that all right you be doing
things that a bit slimy when you're like
this and you got an enemy in front of
you okay but beyond that I don't think
politically we disagree on much I think
we're probably much more aligned than
you to imine so that's what I've always
said listen but I'm going to laugh at
you sometimes when you do some [__] up
[__] play the Olivia somebody again
again so I can remember exactly what
they said okay if you don't know who
Olivia is she's the loser feminist
researcher who spends all her Day on
Reddit boards and thinks that's research
okay that's just [__] mean that was
so
[Music]
unnecessary to be clear the only reason
why I said that okay here's the context
ready for it a big streamer who's a
woman was married she comes out says her
husband's beaten her so everyone wants
to know who the husband is because she's
never mentioned it even though she's
famous the husband's not mhm so they're
on stream live streaming all right and
Olivia's like I'm going to find out who
he is so she goes on Reddit this she's
our D's research she goes on Reddit and
she finds a name and she gives it to
Ethan and Ethan irresponsibly puts it in
the chat for everyone else to go and
doxs this person and start going after
him so they put out his full name
everybody can find him on Instagram he
starts getting a bunch of harassment I'd
like to know who this guy is man I know
who he is does does he have an online
Persona um no he's a produc producer and
songwriter yeah God I hope that man's
life is ruined for this I hope so too F
someone says why are you protecting the
ab's identity I don't give a [__] I
don't give
me yeah I don't give a [__] I want this
guy's life Ru are you kidding me
yep oh is this him yeah I would just be
cautious plat twist plat twist is the
wrong person okay not only did they go
after the wrong person but even if they
went after the wrong person it's
incredibly responsible because let's say
that dude really is a mean person who
beats his wife okay even though we have
no proof of this and it's never been
confirmed even though let's say that is
true then that means this woman who he's
married to is in danger because now he
has more reasons to be angry at her so
you're putting her in physical harm so
we said it's irresponsible on multiple
fronts and that's why I called her the
loser she's a self- admitted feminist so
so the way she found this dude's name
who they incorrectly doxed and she went
on her oh the doxing thing that was such
a silly thing they blew out of
proportion that was the worst day ever I
that's the biggest mistake I've ever
made and I will literally always repent
for
it he's like yo it's not a big thing
it's not she like listen that's the
biggest mistake I made I always repair
for it like how do you have those two
things coexisting literally one after
the other you did to that guy that
innocent guy far worse than we ever did
to you but we're we're we're no we're
not no no for foress for us and you want
to repent my girl repent happened was he
found out the homie that was gasing him
Assan is actually like a giant piece of
[__] that was sending people and his
community after his wife and him and
then he said you know what these guys
were right
about cuz they they cut the podcast you
know they stop doing of course of course
because of the because because he's
Jewish right oh and his uhuh that's
exactly right right it's because I'm
Jewish um well okay so
first let me say this Hassan didn't send
his fans after me I'll just speak on him
a little bit Yeah but also I'll say this
I'm glad they're making fun of him and
not
me you're just glad somebody else is
taking the you're saying you know what I
mean okay that's a I mean that alone is
a Vibe of course but we love his son he
he is
family um it was more so his community
that
uh I don't know if that's a that's a
that's a meaningful difference um well
okay so first let me say this Hassan
didn't send his fans after me I'll just
to speak on him a little bit yeah you're
right I misspoke he didn't send his fans
after you when his moderators and the
people he pays were just calling you all
kinds of slurs and saying all kinds of
foul [__] about your family he didn't
lift a finger to stop them he would a
guy stop and he kept paying them that's
better might not be sending them that's
better he's not you funded them I think
that's kind of worse but that's just me
let's say I ran a
community and my moderators and the
people I pay are saying crazy [__] about
you and your family or one of my homies
you best believe they getting fired the
next day I don't care if we disagree
politically if they talking
crazy
out like a bad [__] what does that mean
I don't
know yes yes I'm getting touched with my
feminine side I Ain red pill I'm trying
to convince Ethan you trying to br
yeah blue pill all day that's how
BL
[__] that's that's all the clip though
I don't think we need to watch
anymore this is all the clip you're just
trying to where they originally said it
right yeah I want to know I mean the
people it's I think it's important to
yeah that that was it I know Olivia
doesn't like to watch any more of this
that's why this is not going how I
imagined it would go anyway I this is
this has gone all
wrong why is it wrong cuz we haven't
that
[__] why is it wrong it's wrong because
the Olivia thing I think like they're
seeing that she's really hurt and
because that they don't want to play
more of it because it's like soured the
mood
listen why you being an [__] today I
don't give a [__] I can see that yeah I
don't give I can't see that what
happened I do not give man man what
happened um [__] that bridge that's what
happened you're going to be but hurt
about that man you taking all this [__]
wrong man whatever man you can be but
hurt if you want to cier
river build a bris and
goer that's wild that's wild I stand by
what I said we didn't say the things
that she claimed and I think it's a bit
dangerous to claim that so that's our
we're covering today's video because of
that statement that was a bit much but
anyways there will be no more videos on
this topic going forward if either wants
to talk we can have a chitchat I'm more
than happy to clear whatever air but no
more of this I just had to do this video
because what they're asserting in this
is really foul um it's against a lot of
the stuff I believe in and it did not
happen so it's important to clear the
record cuz it's just not true